so let me start by saying congrats on
this i thought you did such a great job
with this movie um
i have tons of questions but i like
since i have a little extra time i like
throwing some curveballs at the
beginning that you know just some other
things um and i'm curious and this
question might not apply to you because
i would imagine a lot of people want to
get in business with you and make movies
with you but if you can get the
financing for any project right now what
would you make and why
um
well you know what the project that uh
springs to mind is a project that i hope
i do have the finance for
um there's a project uh there's a book
that i've wanted to get the rights to
for like literally 30 years
um or 31 years um and uh and finally
after all that time i've i think i've
managed to get the rights to it
uh and i hope to be shooting it next
year but i can't tell you what it is so
um i'm gonna frustrate that question
somewhat
is it called in the garden of beasts no
it's not no no so so this is something
completely different completely
different very different
uh i won't pressure you on it i hope it
comes together thank you very much
indeed
um if you've made some very cool movies
if someone had never seen someone has
never seen anything you've directed what
do you want them to start with
well i think i mean i think my favorite
of my movies is um
uh
is atonement
um but do you start with that
and then work down or do you kind of
start with the one that i was less happy
with
and work up to atonement i don't know i
don't know
i asked james mcavoy the same question
recently and he said to start with
atonement did he yeah
i haven't seen james for years i'd love
to see him
yeah he he speaks very highly of that
movie he loves that film
yeah me too it was a special moment
yeah
fantastic movie um would you do another
episode of black mirror
yeah if uh yes i would i i love
charlie's writing
i think he's an extraordinary writer um
i'd prefer to do a kind of um feature
written by charlie
um
and i often say to him come on write a
movie
um but he always kind of demures for
some reason i don't know i'm not quite
sure why but um but yeah i certainly
would always um
uh pretty much jump at the chance of
working with charlie i think he's a
brilliant brilliant writer
i'm fascinated by the editing process of
all movies because that's the final
rewrite it's where it all comes together
which film did you end up in the editing
room with and were like scared if you
will like man this is going to be a
tough edit and which one was like the
breeze
um
well none of them are a breeze
um uh
because
as you say it's it you're you're you're
making your final decisions you know um
throughout the process you can always
say to yourself well you know i don't
have to make a decision on that now i
can either include it or or exclude it
in the edit whereas when you get to the
edit process you're you're faced with
that final
choice so i don't think any of them
um
are a breeze
although having said that the the
process of uh cutting cyrano was a was
was a very very pleasant one uh i uh
because of covert and lockdown um
we edited it in my house
uh in the country uh in england and i
have a barn there and we turned the barn
into a cutting room uh and it was a
a very happy six months but editing is
always weird you know you have to build
your ego up for the shoot
uh you have to kind of build yourself up
to be able to tell
you know 150 350 people um
uh what to do
uh which doesn't come entirely naturally
uh and then in
in in the edit you're kind of
confronted uh uh
by that and and you have to kind of
deconstruct your ego again and and and
face
all the things
all your or
or
all the things you got wrong and all
your failures and
and you'll never stand in an edit going
oh that's a great scene
um you're really you know spending six
months focusing on what doesn't work
rather than what does work
speaking of sereno um what was it
jumping on in what was it about this
material that said i want this this is
going to be my next movie i want to do
this
um
i think i i think it's possibly my most
personal film uh
since
atonement um
i felt very very close
to
[Music]
all of the characters but in particular
cyrano i think he
he somehow got right under my skin i
guess when i was a teenager i kind of
i felt odd and unlovable and
and i still as a lot of us do have
trouble
uh feeling
worthy of of love you know um
and worthy of being treated well
and so um
and so i think that relationship my
relationship with that character
was the kind of deep and personal one
and um
and when i saw
um
uh peter dinklage in the workshop
production i saw uh
uh um
up in connecticut um
a few years ago now i kind of thought
okay this is
this is something i'm interested in
exploring and i want to learn about
uh i think that one of the things that i
really loved is the way you staged so
many of the things in the film a lot uh
i'm just thinking about some of the
musical numbers can you sort of talk
about how you actually went about in
pre-production and figuring out how you
wanted all this to go
yeah it was weird i had a very clear
vision of what i imagined the film to
look and sound like um
right from the beginning i knew that it
would be a kind of
fantasy of a period and a place i had a
sense of the colors i had a sense of the
costumes and i had a sense of the kind
of
uh camera rhythm
and and and movement i knew that
um
you know some of my films recently
really since anna karenina have been
quite
theatrical or presentational in their
style by which i mean using kind of
quite wide-angle lenses and
very kind of specific compositions and
and with this i think possibly because
of the nature of musicals
i felt like i needed a cinematic
aesthetic that was more observational
um
so we used much longer lenses with this
movie and we we tried to create an
atmosphere of spontaneity and and kind
of chaos really
uh which was all very carefully
orchestrated but something that had a
much
um
yeah a much more spontaneous atmosphere
what what ended up being there's always
um i would imagine every director i've
spoken to always talks about how every
movie has unique challenges you have to
overcome uh on this film obviously you
had the covet of it all but besides
covid what what were some of the really
big challenges you had to you know
get over
um
i think there are two sequences really
that were the most challenging the
theater sequence was incredibly
challenging it's a very long scene
um with you know a lot of background
artists um
and it introduces a lot of characters it
moves between
um intimate moments to spectacle
uh back to intimacy and to music and
uh singing and and sword lighting and um
and so to corral all of those different
elements and give them a cohesion
uh
was was
certainly very challenging making sure
that the background
artists felt um a sense of um
ownership of it as well to keep them
kind of engaged and part of it they were
you know the audience was a was a
was a very important character within
the drama
um so that was creatively very
challenging um
uh the other
thing
that was really challenging was shooting
up mount etna
um
uh we had planned uh you know it's a
it's a live volcano
um and we had planned uh to shoot at the
specific site which was 16 000 feet
above sea level so the air is very very
thin
um on these kind of vitigenous um
uh volcanic slopes where you're
constantly sliding down in black uh sand
um but we had been told that it never
snowed up there until february
um and we trusted that information um
and then uh
the week before we were due to uh start
shooting up there
um two and a half meters of snow got
dumped on the mountain um
and uh and suddenly everything changed
and we had to be very reactive to
what
the the the the volcano and and the uh
the weather was giving us and and that
was
possibly the most uh challenging
uh 10 days shoot of my uh career because
i was constantly having to rethink how i
was going to do it all and how i was
gonna stage stuff and
you know the snow um
made things and the and the altitude and
the slope made things very very
difficult on the last day
the the volcano actually erupted
um and uh and
and we had to
run for it um
uh
so um
and and a couple of days later our
entire set was covered in lava
so so that was um
uh probably the most challenging aspect
of the shoe
yeah i think that you that is a unique
answer that i've never heard a director
in my 16 years say
we had to evacuate from a erupting
volcano
yeah that was a bad one that was a bad
one
you know what i'm glad we did it it's a
story that i will always be able to tell
my grandchildren
and
um
and uh
and you know um
filmmaking is also about
adapting and reacting and also it's
about life experiences
and that's certainly one i'll never
forget but also that sequence um looks
fantastic on screen and also filming on
location it adds so much to this movie
it's so good you know like those cobble
cobblestone streets and the locations
you were at you can't recreate that in a
sound stage
no and um
it's the first
movie i've you know all my earlier films
were shot on location
um and then somehow i kind of as if i
retreated into a studio um
uh for at least for the last sort of
three movies um
and so it felt really good to be back on
location uh location shooting again and
that's something i certainly want to
continue to do
i i apologize i don't follow people's
personal lives but i want to say that
you're married to your star
uh uh well yes we have a we have a child
together yes
so yeah it doesn't matter if you're
married but basically you're in a
relation you are a relation with your uh
female lead in the movie uh haley um i i
have to know what is it like directing
someone like that
uh when
um what is it like directing a
significant other
um
well i have to say first of all that she
was
you know um the reason why i went to see
the original workshop production was
because she was in it
um and so uh i had to ask her permission
to um turn it into a movie um
which she granted um
and it was great it was great but we
were just we were just very very
professional and we just got on with our
jobs i'm a huge admirer of her work
um and i think that she is um
she's a bit of a genius really haley and
um
and so um it was wonderful to be able to
uh bring aspects of her work to an
audience that might not necessarily have
previously uh been aware of of
um
might not necessarily have been aware of
yeah she she is excellent in the movie
and uh uh i mean excellent i um i have
to bring up peter because he is also
just so tremendous in the movie and i'm
just curious what is it like directing
someone when you see that they're giving
you so much on screen
um
well it's a joy you know i mean the
great thing about
directing is that you get a front row
seat to these incredible performances
you know
and i am literally in the front row i
sit beside the camera
uh whilst we're filming and um
and there's nothing between me and the
actor
um and i'm and i'm talking to him i'm
talking to them um
and
uh and it's uh
you know it's he's incred
the the lovely thing about pete is that
he is
incredibly technically skilled
um and also
has a
well of deep deep human emotion um and
that's you know often you don't get one
without you know often you get one but
not the other
um but to get that combination in a
single actor is is is thrilling and
exciting it means that he's very
um responsive to direction
um you can
you know you can calibrate a performance
um
with kind of detailed notes and he can
play them
beautifully and beyond your wildest
imagination
and it's a great privilege to just to
just be a witness
to such talent
flowering
um uh
i'm being given the wrap-up signal but i
just want to ask you one last thing um
going into the editing of this film did
you have a much longer cut how did the
the film possibly change in the editing
room uh i love learning about that kind
of stuff
um
well
i i
believe in meticulous preparation
uh during pre-production and
um and i and i work very hard on the
development of the screenplay
um and so
i hope that when i start editing or
start shooting a movie
it's pretty much going to be
uh what appears
on the screen um
so no there wasn't a much longer cut i
think the original
the first assembly was two hours 40
minutes
um
which is about normal for me um and the
finished film is just under two hours
the first 20 minutes
you can take out in the first week of
post and that's easy the second uh 20
minutes or the second kind of
10
to 13 minutes uh you have to spend about
a month trying to kind of sift through
um and then that last seven minutes is
always a uh an absolute
um
uh uh
[ __ ] to try and to try and lose um
uh that's where it gets that's where it
gets painful but um
i love i love the cutting process um
uh
it's something that it really appeals to
my kind of strange non-linear brain um
uh it's um
it's it's something that i really love
i have to stop there i'm just gonna say
seriously man congratulations on the
movie i hope it's a huge hit for you you
did such a great job with it
thank you steve lovely to see you again
mate hopefully we'll see each other
again in person one one day down there a
happy road to destiny and i do hope that
this book that you're trying to make uh
you're able to make it oh thank you
bless you cheers thanks have a great day
man
bye
you